book notes every sunday at 8 p.m eastern
end pacific on c-span
washington journal continues
welcome back to washington journal for
about the next hour we're joined by the
author of this book which is called
secrecy and power the life of j edgar
hoover by richard good powers
mr powers thank you very much for being
with us this morning glad to be with you
and uh i want to ask you i want to open
up we're going to talk about j edgar
hoover for about the next hour and his
impact on american law enforcement and
on civil rights in the united states let
me ask you a question i just asked of
the
website administrator recently
20 minutes ago what are the best and
worst things that j edgar hoover did in
his career
at several moments in the nation's
history when
the
country needed reassurance and needed a
sense of security and that was primarily
during the depression of the 1930s and
during world war ii
hoover gave them that sense of security
and so he supplied the country with
something that it needed very badly
that was the best thing that he did the
worst thing that he did was to stay on
too long to the point where his personal
idiosyncrasies and they weren't very
pleasant ones they were an antipathy to
nearly any kind of dissent in the
country
turned the fbi into a repressive
organization
and perhaps even worse a secret
repressive organization that was doing
things that were illegal and it was
keeping them from the attention of the
attorney general and the president
now you've got some terrific pictures in
the book and maybe we can show those in
a minute here
the young j edgar hoover tell us a
little bit about what he was like when
he was growing up he was born right here
in washington dc was he not he was he
was born behind the capitol building
rather near the library of congress
he came from a civil servant family he
was born in 1895
and he participated in the
life of middle class white
civil servant washington he was an
upwards driver and he went to the best
public high school in washington
he
excelled at school he also excelled as a
leader he was the head of the cadet
corps which was a an important
after school's activity in those days he
was also a prize debater
but perhaps one of the most important
things about his boyhood was that
washington d.c was a relatively late
place to be segregated
it began to be segregated while j edgar
hoover was a young boy and so
during his most formative years one of
the primary impressions that he received
was that a respectable society should be
segregated and furthermore an elite
organization meant a lilly white
organization if we'd met him when he was
in his teens and early 20s what kind of
a guy would we have expected to see
well first of all
and a lot of people will uh be surprised
at this i think you would have found him
likable and impressive in a uh an eager
beaver uh kind of way
he was someone of tremendous intensity
uh he was a person that
would
give you 150 percent of any effort that
was required
and as a result particularly when he was
given his first jobs in the justice
department
his superiors were
seasoned politicians and perhaps even
politicians somewhat over the hill
and they were kind of bowled over by his
energy and so initially it was his
competence and his just fierce energy
that set him apart from his competitors
i want to invite our viewers and our
listeners into this conversation we have
three lines democrats can call in
202-585-3881
republicans 202-585-3
and independence and everybody else 202
585-3882 we're talking with richard good
powers he's the author of secrecy and
power the life of j edgar hoover what
was his first
real job coming out of school and it's
after he got his law degree at george
washington university here in in d.c
practically simultaneously with getting
that degree he went into the justice
department it's a little unclear what
his title was he was a clerk and he was
in an organization called the alien
enemy bureau
and an alien enemy is a particular legal
category that the president proclaims
after declaration of war and what it
means is that people who are citizens of
a country that the united states is
fighting are liable to internment and
hoover's job initially was to go through
applications for exemption from
internment and so he was thrown right
into
the problem of dealing with uh
immigrants who were suspicious in one
way or another and probably
a suspicion of immigrants was something
that stayed with him the rest of his
life all the way through until his
anti-communist days after world war ii
exactly and uh how did he get we wanted
we've got calls coming in for you
already but you wanted to one quick
thing here how did he get to what was
then called the bureau of investigation
in
uh april and may of 1919 there were a
series of bomb attacks terrorist bomb
explosions throughout the country
and in the summer of 1919 the attorney
general of the united states a mitchell
palmer decided to form an anti-radical
division of the justice department and
he put j edgar hoover in charge of it
now jade hoover was only 24 years old at
the time initially he was a special
assistant to the attorney general but in
essence he was supervising the bureau of
investigations most important work
and around 1920
he was shifted over to and that division
was shifted over to the bureau of
investigation our first call for richard
good powers comes from fort smith
arkansas on her line for republicans
good morning
so i was one to ask the author if he had
read the cold 6000 or american tabloid
by james elroy
and wanted to see if he could get his
comment on the two novels i'm a big fan
of his writing and i just want to know
what he thought i'll hang up and listen
thank you bye
well i'm afraid give a very short answer
that haven't read them okay let's go to
uh landover maryland on our line for
democrats good morning yes sir how are
you today
i didn't i haven't had the pleasure of
reading your book sir but i have read
jagger hoover the man and the secrets by
kurt gentry and in his book he pretty
much outlines jacob hoover as public
enemy number one uh more or less the
same line he gave about the people he
was trying to capture he had his people
uh try to arrest because he never
arrested hardly anyone
one of the things that he mentioned is
that jacob hoover
and his boyfriend who was the second
command tollson had a secret slush fund
uh called the uh fbi recreational fund
and he had pretty much fbi agents
writing books for him
uh ghost writers more or less on public
time and he used the money from these
books to uh he put that in the so-called
fbi recreational fund where only he
tolston and his uh third in command lou
nichols had access to and they used the
money to go to florida and all these
other places and strangely enough in
looking at
the pictures you have they're the same
pictures that are in this kurt gentry
book as well i'll hang up and listen to
your comment
well as far as the pictures are
concerned my book did come out first on
the other hand there's a limited number
of pictures they're largely in the
national archives and gentry
went to the same source as i did
gentry's book is a pretty good book he's
a tremendous researcher and he dug up
some terrific sources
he does take as his guiding line you
might say
a
a revisionist anti-j edgar hoover
perspective which doesn't mean that any
of his facts are wrong but that there is
a particular slant to them
as far as this slush fund is concerned
pretty much everything that you've
specified is accurate on the other hand
i would say that there's no evidence
that
it was
totally misused in the sense that you're
saying most of the money did go into fbi
recreational activities
and
in the context of the times
the idea of conflict of interest laws
and
the
the technicalities surrounding this sort
of activity were not as tightly etched
as they are today but i have to say
guilty as charged to everything you were
saying richard good powers through the
this caller raised an issue that i think
we're going to get to eventually during
this hour and that is the relationship
between j edgar hoover and his second in
command clyde tolson got a photograph
here of the two of them at a nightclub
in new york uh tell us a little bit
about that there's a lot of innovations
that the two of them had an intimate
relationship what what's the story there
well this is an instance where i'm
afraid i'd have to depart from your
orders to stick with short answers
because it's uh it's somewhat involved
but i'll try to make it as brief as i
can
tolson was someone who came into the
bureau about 1929
and had a meteoric arise in about two or
three years he was an assistant director
of the fbi and he was j edgar hoover's
inseparable companion
there were intimations suggestions
throughout hoover's life that he was
homosexual
and the most likely uh
partner uh certainly was clyde tolson as
i said they really were inseparable from
the early 30s until hoover died
now in my book i did find some
interesting facts that led me in a
certain direction
i found some photographs that hoover had
taken of tolson while tolson was
sleeping
and i think that
most men would recognize that this is
somewhat of an
unforgivable invasion of privacy for one
man to do to another unless there was
something going on between them
secondly at one point hoover was asked
to investigate an assistant a deputy
secretary of state who had made a
homosexual pass at a pullman porter and
was going to lose his job because of it
and he was asked to find out what had
happened and hoover made a very
interesting statement he said that well
this only happened when this fellow is
drunk
and in that
circumstance it shows that all of us
have to be on guard
against giving in to those kind of
inclinations well
i don't think that most heterosexual men
would feel that they were in any great
danger of making a pass at a pullman
porter if they were drunk so in both of
those instances it leads you to move in
a certain direction what i what i call
the relationship was a spousal
relationship
there really is no evidence there was a
sexual relationship
but
uh
you know sex is a powerful force and
given the opportunity etc etc uh i would
tend to
move in that direction myself uh in that
conclusion although
once again there is no hard and fast
evidence that someone once said uh the
people who know aren't talking people
who talk don't know but let's move on to
the or
do you want me to continue on with this
question right now because this moves
then into the transvestite issue well
sure why don't we why don't we just get
to that right now and talk about that
okay that comes out of another biography
of hoover by anthony summers a british
journalist and what he claimed in that
book was that he had a witness
who had seen jack hoover in a dress for
the moment i can't remember whether it
was a a red dress a white dress but
anyway it was a puffy party dress along
with several other notorious characters
at one of new york hotels
and he actually got this woman not only
to give him a quote to that effect but
in a promo for his book to go on camera
and say that she had seen this
at the time i thought this story was
extremely suspicious that there were all
sorts of logical reasons why it couldn't
be true
i got in touch with the woman and i
wanted to talk to her and at first she
said she would then she said she would
if i paid her and then finally
it was for a very large sum of money and
then finally she wouldn't talk to me at
all and it seemed to me that someone
might have been
influencing her not to talk to me
she was undergoing a very messy divorce
she was a
the wife of the owner of uh seagram
distillers
uh if i have that right
anyway schenley
distillers
and
in the midst of this divorce her
estranged husband supposedly came to her
and said come with me to
the waldorf hotel and i'll show you
something interesting he brought her to
the hotel and then he hoover
tolson roy cohn put on a homosexual orgy
for her entertainment is that something
that a
husband who is
divorcing his wife and is in the midst
of legal proceedings is likely to be
doing doesn't make much sense to me
furthermore
the idea behind the whole story is the
following
the mob supposedly had gotten hold of
this information
and therefore they were able to
blackmail hoover into not investigating
the mob
let's carry the story a little bit
further because this is all in somer's
book also he claims that the mob also
had
sexual information about president
kennedy and that kept kennedy from
investigating the mob and finally that
hoover had evidence of jfk's sexual
shenanigans so that jfk couldn't order
hoover round the only problem with the
whole story is that we all know that
once the hoovers that once the kennedys
took control of the white house and
justice department they did unleash the
fbi against the mob and the fbi pursued
them vigorously
so the story itself seems very
suspicious to me and the upshot the
implication of it one last factor there
have been two books specifically
touching on this topic one was by ethan
theo harris and he wrote a book sex
lives and j edgar hoover i think was a
title in which he gave his arguments why
the story is not to be believed that
hoover was a transvestite then the most
recent book a darn good book by ron
kessler called the bureau of history the
fbi
uh really nailed the story he did manage
to talk to rose and steele and
i think exposed her as a very unreliable
witness all right let's take a call for
richard good powers from cherry hill new
jersey on our line for democrats good
morning yes hello um i want to take you
in a slightly different direction and go
back to the comments that mr hoover was
not favorable to immigrants and
some of the repressive acts that took
place in the fbi while he was leading it
i'm wondering what um
what lessons you would draw
from those
from the research you did particularly
in the cohen's health pro period
as we look at the implementation of the
u.s patriot act today
that's a really good question because
the
there are some parallels here
first and foremost uh hoover's fbi
really went wildly astray starting about
1955. what had happened was that the
bureau had been able to surveil
communists
justifying it because the communists
were at least plausibly in violation of
the smith act which meant that uh if
they belonged to an organization that
advocated the overthrow of the
government it could be indicted so in
other words the fbi had a legal hook to
hang its investigations on in 1955 the
supreme court said that it was not going
to countenance any more prosecutions
based on the smith act essentially uh
saying that it was unconstitutional
although it never quite came to that
so the fbi did something that was at
this
uh perspective now absolutely
unjustified they decided that they would
secretly begin to use
counterintelligence techniques to
disrupt and harass the communist party
and they commenced to do so
now
within a few years uh under the kennedy
administration they began to use the
same techniques against the ku klux klan
in this case they didn't notify their
superiors then they went on to use the
same techniques against black panthers
and other black nationalist groups and
finally they were using them well
against the socialist workers party but
they were also using them against the
student anti-war movement and the key
thing here is that they do we're doing
things that were illegal
and just plain wrong
against american citizens uh who might
have been unpopular but were not uh
accused or guilty of any crimes and this
is uh
uh you know an object lesson in what we
must never allow a law enforcement
organization to do
now under the patriot act
you do have
a mechanism for unleashing the bureau to
do intelligence gathering operations
which means potentially at least they
can gather information about groups who
as of the moment have not committed any
crimes and maybe there's no evidence
that they are going to commit any crimes
on the other hand
there's nothing in the patriot act that
would uh countenance disruptive
activities of the sort that you had in
cointelpro uh they were really illegal
then and they're illegal now
our next call callous bella montana line
for republicans good morning
good morning
i uh
don't quite understand what that guy is
getting at i
was just a kid growing up when he
uh when the jail hoover started in there
but he made
the
the fbi an organization that was
had the risk
the
good
feelings of other
law for enforcement agencies and in his
book that he had
he said he made the statement that a
communist is a communist as a communist
and
and that was absolutely 100 percent true
and still is but you can't tell it by
the way some of our politicians now
they're still trying to deal with him
you cannot deal with a communist unless
he knows you've got the absolute power
to make him do so that's that's going to
respond caller
well the the phrase the communists as a
communist as a communist uh
uh is sort of true on the face face of
it but even j edgar hoover realized that
it led him astray in one particular
instance after the assassination of john
f kennedy uh he
really went through
uh
you know like a whirlwind his top
officials figuring out what had gone
wrong he considered this to be the worst
disaster in the history of the fbi
and he was told that the fbi had a
series of perhaps it had a checklist
perhaps of 10 points
that a uh an individual had to fit into
before he would be investigated he have
to see he had to subscribe to the daily
worker he had to go to communist party
meetings etc etc this meant that the fbi
was surveilling some over the hill party
hacks who weren't doing much except
sitting around in parks and playing
chess and on the other hand they were
not keeping their eye on lee harvey
oswald who was a self-proclaimed
communist and who was
obviously dangerous
and when one of his top officials
tried to excuse themselves by saying
that
lee harvey oswald didn't fit all the
criterion
hoover himself said that anyone in the
world could have seen this was exactly
the sort of person they should have been
watching so a communist as a communist
as a communist it may be true in some
senses but
law enforcement has to be a little more
discriminating than that richard good
powers let me take you back to uh the
the
early 20 or the late 20s early 30s which
i think is is judging from your book
when j edgar hoover became begin to
become a famous public figure give us a
sense of what it was like back then your
book suggests that the crime situation
was out of control and quite different
from the way it is today
the the situation
uh as far as crime was concerned in the
early depression is very interesting
it's almost a
a case study in political psychology
what happened was you had a fair amount
of crime during the 1920s but after the
crash crime began to be interpreted by
the public as a test of whether the
government was able to do its job and
under president herbert hoover no
relation to j edgar hoover it seemed
that the government was not able to do
its job because in some of the high
profile crimes and some of the
high-profile criminals of time al capone
the lindbergh kidnapping the government
was not able to react quickly enough and
it was not able to react in a way that
the public really
interpreted as the right
response
so when
the roosevelt administration came in
with a new attorney general
and they began to interpret
crimes high-profile crimes as challenges
to the country declarations of war by
criminals against the country it was
something that the public really exalted
in and when hoover managed to capture or
kill people like machine gun kelly
babyface nelson pretty boy floyd and of
course john dillinger uh it really was
interpreted by the country as a
tremendous boost to its self-confidence
this really meant that the country even
though it was in very hard times was
going to survive with its value system
intact that criminals were not going to
rule the country and then hollywood took
over hollywood made a series of g-men
pictures beginning in 1935
it turned the fbi and it turned jade
hoover into popular celebrities and that
was really what made j edgar hoover too
big for anyone to touch
now he added dimensions to that
afterwards but once he became a
hollywood hero
he was something that was really
operating on a whole different level
than a normal politician and certainly a
normal bureaucrat
now
he had a talent for being at the scene
of the arrest of some of these guys did
he not
in the mid 30s
one of his congressional opponents a
senator mckellar
ridiculed him during an appropriations
committee meeting uh hearing that he had
never actually arrested anyone himself
and so for the next two years or so
you couldn't keep jade group in the
office he showed up to arrest the then
public enemy number one alvin creepy
carpus on canal street in new orleans
he arrested
harry brunetti here in new york city
and it was clearly quite a spectacle um
at that point uh j edgar hoover was in
his 40s and you know he was really a
bureaucrat a high level administrator
yet he was running around the country
slapping the cuffs on on people so it
was really
quite a spectacle
but it was something that was
precipitated by a confrontation that he
had with one senator
our next call for richard goodpowers
from hamilton montana on our line for
democrats good morning
good morning
good morning jeremy yep are you fine
okay i wanted to mention something about
j edgar hoover
i'm from la jolla california i'm a lady
with la jolla and he used to come to la
jolla to go to scripps clinic for his
annual checkup
i worked at a very elite resort there at
the time of the mccarthy hearings
and uh he stayed at this resort in a
little bungalow with clyde tolson
he was a very pleasant man now one day
i'll get to the point fast
we had all our our
cars out so
mccarthy's brother was to arrive at the
airport that's joe mccarthy's brother
and they had no one to go in and pick
him up so they asked if i would go pick
him up i said sure i picked him up
and uh i did so took him to la jolla and
joe mccarthy's brother with his little
briefcase headed right for that bungalow
no stops so i've always figured in the
years in between that there was a
connection here between him and hoover
and you know the communist uprising that
they had over the actors and writers in
hollywood
and i'm sure there's a connection there
but i could never figure it out
but anyway i wanted to say also that the
man was always very pleasant to me clyde
tilson was always very pleasant and
as far as immigrants are concerned my
father was an immigrant and they sure
treated him well he was in the
restaurant business and they
frequented his restaurant and liked him
and he liked them so there you go you
know there's two sides to every person
okay caller thanks
mr powers any response to that the
connection between joe mccarthy and
well there certainly was a connection
between hoover and mccarthy
mccarthy was a
completely irresponsible anti-communist
who was liable to say the first thing
that came into his head
and then he would run to hoover asking
for some facts to back it up
and hoover was in a position where he
couldn't quite repudiate mccarthy
because mccarthy was enormously popular
among hoover's own backers that would be
the
right wing of the country
on the other hand he knew that mccarthy
was really bad news for the
anti-communist movement because he would
be caught up eventually in his own lives
that's what happened and whoever had a
very key point in uh
the decline and fall of joe mccarthy did
publicly repudiate him
as far as the other point is concerned
about hoover's attitude towards
immigrants
i really was too sweeping in that
statement before where i said he was
suspicious of immigrants uh he was
suspicious of
radicalism and he thought that
radicalism was a foreign import
and so
it's more proper to say that he was
suspicious of radicalism among
immigrants
houston texas good morning you're on
c-span
hi
oh there was a book written about five
years ago about hoover having black
ancestry and matter of fact the lady she
looked at his birth certificate and
found that it was tampered with maybe
that was one of the reason why
hoover had a hard time with blacks
because of his secret past
the book was written about five years
ago do you have any comments about that
book have you ever read it yeah i have
read it i have looked into the book and
um i'm very skeptical about nearly
everything that's in the book
and one of the things that uh you can
look for yourself is if you get my book
you can look at pictures of hoover's
mother and then look at pictures of
hoover and we know what uh who hoover's
mother was and we know her ancestry
which was a a swiss ancestry and you
know they are uh
amazingly similar
uh actually there's a picture they're
flashing right up there now and uh
that does look like hoover in a black
dress doesn't it
i don't think that there's anything to
it on the other hand uh
hoover did have in some sense some
features that were if you want
stereotypically uh negro features he had
a broad lips uh his hair was very
tightly curly and so
you know i can see how someone would
move in that direction but i'm very
skeptical of the woman's conclusions and
of the facts that she brings to bear
our next call comes from santa barbara
california good morning good morning
yes i've been waiting for your call
anyway i do want to disagree with a few
things but
i had a very good privilege i was uh
sticky with a princess many years ago i
had a talk show in bakersfield
california
and one of my guests was a princess who
had escaped from communism in remedia
her name was princess catherine caraja i
could send you her information if you
want it
uh what i was first called asked if i
would like to have her on my show i was
thrilled to death of course and
announced on the air that she would be
speaking on communism
when i picked her up at the station
she became furious i am not going to be
talking about communism well needless to
say i was shocked
what are you going to be talking about
your topic
i'm going to be talking how you
americans are losing your freedoms
through your apathy and your complacency
and look what's happened
i frankly wish we had jaeger who were
back
he may have been homosexual i don't care
for that that's not the point
but we did not have the traitors that we
have at least as far as i know we do not
have the traitors then
that we have today
we did not have half hanson
and a few of the other things because uh
he ran a bureau
that was free of them
but uh i heard angela davis week are you
uh
uh so i heard angela jameson the first
time she spoke at ucla who advocated the
overthrow of the united states
government for our tax supported campus
i happened to be a public speaker
inhabited for many years and i got up
and argued with her
when she found out that i was not in her
camp she they tried to take the
microphone away from me
and i wouldn't let them anyway i finally
said to her
could you possibly speak of capitalism
in russia that is completely irrelevant
i said the heck it is
okay let's get a response here
is it true there have been some highly
publicized uh revelations of spies
inside the cia yeah inside the fbi
lately
was that true during the hoover era or
not
no it was not
and
i think that an awful lot of laxity had
crept into the bureau in the post hoover
era
hoover's
uh control of his agents was uh
really all-encompassing his goal really
wasn't an agent could literally do
nothing at all uh minute by minute
without reporting on what he was doing
to his superiors and eventually to
hoover
and so
i think it was
almost beyond comprehension or beyond
credibility that an agent could become a
spy could become a mole in the hoover
era fbi
and
in reaction to that there probably had
been and to a certain extent still is
too much relaxation of these
internal controls over fbi agents so the
fbi really has been hit by some
incredibly disgraceful incidents where
their own agents have turned out to be
traitors against the country
and
to give hoover his due i doubt that
would have been possible in his era
richard good powers we have a photo here
of the
bureau of investigation in the early
days and tell us a little this is
something i keep trying to get back to
and we keep getting taken in other
directions but before we lose the
opportunity what why how did j edgar
hoover come to be director and what did
he do to change the nature of that
bureau when he did become director
the
the
time when hoover was
moved up to director of the fbi first
assistant
acting director of the fbi was in 1923
when the country was
caught up in a series of government
scandals called the teapot dome scandals
and the department of justice was
discredited and the bureau of
investigation was particularly
discredited
so hoover was appointed assistant
director and then in 1924 i'm yeah
assistant director and then in 1924
he was appointed director of the bureau
by
harlan stone
and what he was told to do was to remove
the bureau from any investigations that
did not pertain to federal crimes
and to strictly limit his investigations
to cut down on the number of agents and
so forth so it was a disgraced bureau
and his job for the first say eight or
nine years that he was director was to
keep the fb out of the fbi out of the
news
and what he did he was a very energetic
person he wasn't
content to do less and less every year
is he made the fbi the leader of the
police professionalism movement in the
country which put the fbi
in the vanguard of a movement started by
other people actually started by a
berkeley california
police chief and by a few other
progressive police chiefs throughout the
country but the fbi became the symbol of
police professionalism which meant
independence from politics and the use
of scientific law enforcement
and so by the time the roosevelt
administration for political reasons
began to publicize the bureau the bureau
was already very well known in law
enforcement community and highly
respected
our next call for richard good powers
comes from kearney nebraska on our line
for democrats good morning
yes i'd like to know did not the fbi
know that patty hearst was going to be
abducted
no the fbi didn't know she was going to
be abducted
all right let's go to uh madison
wisconsin on our line for independence
good morning good morning uh thanks for
taking my call uh in reading the book
the birth of stalin
there's a a couple of statements on 183
and it relates to
this was uncovered when they released
some of the doc secret documentation in
the archives over and i believe moscow
and it was a memo from boris reinstein
who was a
communist sympathizer in this country
and he wrote a note to
lenin
and
he lennon made some notes and passed on
to stalin and it had to do with comrade
julius hammer and his son
armin
and the fact that
dr julie's hammer was one of the main
financial razors of money for the
communist party back in those days
and lenin
the letter he passed on indicated how
important it was to keep this
secret so that it would not be uncovered
now in other books that i've read
i've understood that
j edgar hoover was on to the hammer
family
and their support for communism but that
three senators namely al gore senior
and i believe the senator from new
hampshire and one other from the
northeast
put us
more or less a stop to putting
them in jail and of course the son
armenhammer became a primary supporter
of al gore in his various runs for
president back in 88 and since then
also headed up occidental petroleum who
my understanding is that
al gore jr pushed through this largest
sale in the history of the nation of
public land to a private concern and
actually it was occidental okay let's
get a response here
well i'm familiar with the broad
[Music]
issues involved in the arm and hammer
career and
hammer and his
family
you know we're deeply involved in
couriering
uh
money from the soviet union to the
american communist party and furthermore
uh in i guess repayment for that service
uh hammer was given all sorts of
concessions in the soviet union as far
as doing business was concerned
so there's no doubt that
hammer was deeply involved in activities
that were
opposed to the interests of the united
states but as far as the specifics in
relationships between hammer and the
gore family i'm not familiar with those
but i would say that hammer had managed
to acquire so much influence that i
would not be surprised if you weren't
able to find a much broader spectrum of
congressmen and senators who also came
to the aid of hammer when he asked for
that aid
and none of them presumably were aware
of his activities
richard good powers we have an email
from a viewer who asks lust for big
money seems to be the reason for all our
troubles observing what's going on today
what was hoover's salary in his day and
did he die wealthy
whoever did die rather wealthy and
the
the source of the wealth were
tips given to him on oil investments by
his wealthy texas
oil interest friends
the murchison's uh hunts among others
so uh he was more than lucky
as far as his investments were concerned
he was brought into good things
repeatedly as far as his salary was
concerned
you know he was paid a
a government service administration
salary according to his rank and
while it was
you know a nice sum of money it wasn't
anything extraordinary and it certainly
was nothing comparable to what he could
have made in private industry and by the
way you have the same problem today if
indeed it's a problem
and that is that to administer an
organization like the fbi uh takes a
fantastic amount of administrative
talent and yet the head of the fbi uh
makes only in a neighborhood of 150 000
and in the case of last director louis
free that turned into an enormous
financial sacrifice since he had a good
number of children who were approaching
college age
richard goodpowers is the author of this
book the life of secrecy and power the
life of j edgar hoover he got his phd at
brown university in what mr powers
american civilization
and now directs the graduate program in
american studies at the city university
of new york teaches history at the
college of staten island been studying
the fbi since 1975 lives alternately in
brooklyn and new orleans why those two
places
my wife is the headmistress of a very
fine girl school in new orleans louise s
mcgee school and naturally i want to
spend as much time as i can with her
you know as somebody who's lived in new
orleans if you'll permit me to observe
that the accent in both brooklyn and new
orleans is very similar you find that to
be the case amazingly so
our next call for richard goodpowers
comes from centerville virginia good
morning good
morning um
uh talking about the transvestite
stories about mr hoover uh it's the
funny thing that i read in the newspaper
uh a while back
that this was one of the
lies of
kgb disinformation
that was put out by the
russians
and it was revealed when the kgb files
were opened and that was one of the
things that came out i read it in the
newspaper i'm surprised that you don't
know about that
well i don't know about a lot of things
that's not too surprising in that
particular instance i hadn't heard that
story
all right let's go to
germantown tennessee good morning good
morning and thank you this is very
interesting i'm fascinated with hoover
i would like to
say something real quick and then ask
three short questions
someone said something about hoover
being good there's a wonderful quote
from john dos pasos if there's one thing
that mankind should have learned from
all of its agonies
it is never safe to do evil that good
may come of it the good gets lost and
the evil goes on and that's one of my
problems with mr hoover he seemed to
have so many dichotomies about what he
was
and the first question i'd like to ask
is you mentioned the one thing that you
thought hoover did wrong was he stayed
too long did anyone ever approach or
attempt or try to get hoover to move on
out in his twilight years
yes attorney general herbert brownell
around 1959
uh went to hoover and told him that it
is time for you to move on
and that if you continue in office
you're going to taint
a fantastic reputation that you've built
up over the years
hoover ignored that advice and perhaps
the reason ignored the advice is he was
a single man
his whole life was wrapped up in the
bureau
he didn't like the changes that were
occurring in the united states and so he
kept the bureau a kind of
well
almost theme park if you want to use
kind of an inappropriate term a theme
park in which was encapsulated the kind
of america he grew up in
and so there was really no place for
hoover outside the fbi and he didn't
particularly like what was outside the
fbi so he did stay on he stayed on and
he turned himself into
worse than just a curmudgeon
somebody who was opposing often secretly
what
large
uh
segments of the public thought was
necessary which was a change in the
racial
relationships in the country
a
greater tolerance of diversity and
dissent in the country and so he turned
himself and the fbi into forces that
were really trying to thwart some of the
major tendencies in america at the time
all right i think that do we still have
that last caller on the line yes yes
you've got a couple more questions
i missed i missed the first part of your
question just remind me i'll get back to
it uh well
i'd like to move on to something else
recently there were suggestions made
that
the fbi building which has j edgar
hoover's name on it should be renamed in
light of all that has come to surface in
the many books i'd like to know what
your feeling is on that i think a great
title for it would just be put the
following quote up there absolute power
corrupts and it corrupts absolutely
caller did you have one more thing you
wanted to ask before we let you go
yes
am i on yeah yeah i'll just see a quick
last question
i i'd like to know what he thinks about
the suggestion for renaming the fbi
building from the j edgar hoover
building to another something else okay
thanks
yeah i'd be completely opposed to that
and i say that recognizing uh you know
the motives behind what you've said and
about behind the suggestion by the way
it's a suggestion that a columnist for
washington post makes repeatedly and a
number of people in congress have made
but you really can't wipe out a
a whole era of the nation's past
just because of
the changing attitudes toward it i think
actually it's better to keep the name on
there as a reminder to the fbi
both of some of the glorious parts of
its past but also reminding it of how
much it had gone astray in the past i
don't really think you should blank out
things like that was there any
controversy about naming the building
for j edgar hoover when it was named for
him no at that point uh you have to bear
in mind he died in 1972
and uh while he was really cordially
hated by the left
in this country and to a certain extent
uh
within the liberal community as well
the
evidence
for his misdeeds had not come out until
1975.
and so you had a period in between where
while he certainly was a controversial
figure and certainly there were people
who had no use for him you didn't have
hard and fast evidence of what he had
done that was illegal until 1975 when
there was a
a senatorial
investigation headed by frank church of
idaho phoenix arizona good morning
you're on c-span with richard good
powers yeah good morning thank you i
just agree about that not renaming it i
see just
name the building the fbi building
because i just finished reading a book
i don't know if you've read it it's
called the secret life of j edgar hoover
by anthony summers
i have read it yes yeah and i uh find
some disturbing evidence in there and
i don't know if it's fact or in fiction
or what you know what it is but one of
the things i saw just he didn't really
like the kennedys too much
and i'm wondering
uh did he know that the assassination
was going to take place did he know lee
harvey off all
thank you very much yes well that's a
really important question first of all
he did not like the kennedys i didn't
like him for a number of reasons and one
is that they were pushing him uh in
directions that he didn't want to go as
far as integrating the fbi was concerned
he was also being pushed by them to
engage in civil rights investigations
that he didn't feel would be fruitful as
far as convictions were concerned and
also ran against his own prejudices
against blacks and his view of the
proper place of blacks in american
society which was in a subordinate
position
as far as lee harvey oddsworld was
concerned no the fbi
did not know that oswald is going to
assassinate
the
john f kennedy
but they probably should have been a lot
more suspicious no not probably they
certainly should have more been more
suspicious of him and they should have
kept him under tighter surveillance
after all and i'm sure you're aware of
this
oswald went into the dallas fbi uh field
office and threatened the agents there
with violence if they didn't stop
harassing him and his wife now it seems
to me and it seemed to almost anyone
that that in itself is reason to keep
him under very tight surveillance
particularly since he had this uh
extremely unusual background of having
defected to the soviet union of having
come back of having gotten involved in
uh very extreme
uh ant uh
pro castro activities of having applied
for membership in the american communist
party there are all sorts of reasons why
the fbi should have been on to this
character and yet they did not keep them
under surveillance mr powers in your
book there's a copy of a memorandum and
uh j edgar hoover's handwriting is here
in which he calls martin luther king a
tomcat with abs with
looks like degenerate sexual urges can
you tell us what that was all about
martin luther king jr
was the target of probably the worst of
all of the fbi harassment
finally uh one of hoover's top
lieutenants a man named william c
sullivan
sent martin luther king jr a letter
actually addressed so that it would
arrive at his house where his wife would
open it in which it accused who um king
of uh
uh sexual
uh
crimes sexual offenses and then said to
king there's only one way out and it
seemed unmistakable to what the letter
was doing was suggesting suicide to king
so that's how bad it got
now the the background for this which
has really been developed by a terrific
historian named david garrow
is that the fbi had an informant
within the communist party who notified
the bureau that one of martin luther
king jr's top advisors had been a very
important member of the communist party
had dropped out and so therefore might
be a mole and so at that point hoover
launched which uh an investigation which
in the context of today was a legitimate
investigation to find out the extent of
communist influence on martin luther
king jr in the course of that
investigation
hoover uncovered
king's
secret sex life
and that was something that hoover then
began to use against king once king
emerged as a critic of the fbi because
probably worse than being a communist
and worse than than a public official
who was leading a secret sex life was
to be a critic of the fbi that meant
that you were an enemy of everything
that was good and everything that was
american and so from that point on uh
hoover pitted himself as a sworn enemy
of martin luther king jr and began to
try to use evidence sexual evidence
against king
jupiter florida good morning you're on
c-span good morning how are you
i'd what i'd like to address uh you know
his sexuality sexuality i i've known
this man for
many years i'm from baltimore and he
used to go to all the racetracks
and i remember one day out there when
seabiscuit was running against whirlaway
in that very very famous race back in
the 40s
and he was surrounded by all women and i
must have seen him a hundred times at
bowie and laurel and pimlico
and i disagree with some of these people
that call in
thank you very much
well i would just refer back to my
statements before which is that
there are
suggestive bits of evidence that point
you in the direction of suspecting that
he was you can also use the word
homosocial which means preferring the
company of men
there is no evidence at all that hoover
was heterosexual
he certainly did have
women among his friends
but then as i said before the people
that really know aren't talk and the
people who are talking really don't know
when it comes to his
las vegas nevada good morning yeah good
morning
i'd like to just uh i had a different
experience with mr
j edgar hoover
i i lived in vallejo during
just after around
the bombing of pearl harbor and
a family friend of mine were of japanese
they were americans but they were
japanese descent so they were shipped
off to internment and their property was
taken by americans at 10 cents on the
dollar which you know i i always felt
this was the worst thing we ever did to
anybody
and uh so in ninth uh i got uh during
the war i got uh
hooked up with the
remnants of the 442nd and the and uh
111th battalion of nisi
and ever since then i've been i was on a
little bit of a
thing i
i ended up doing a pro bono
i tried to
lobby congress to give these people the
right to become citizens these people
because of the asian exclusion during
those years and in the 50s they couldn't
even become citizens yet they fought
unlike one of our presidents uh mr
reagan
and like the duke wayne who didn't go to
war these guys went but they couldn't
become citizens so i went back and
and i
lobbied for nothing to get this bill
through and i had to go see mr hoover
because everybody told me i better do it
so he graciously gave me one hour didn't
know me from adam
and we talked over the whole problem and
i i consider even though he may have
some
little problems he sure gave me a lot of
help and he told me you know a couple
little stories to use on some of the
senators and some of the house of
representatives so
uh he gave me a big boost on getting
this thing through and it's one of i
think i i really felt good about getting
this through for the people who
couldn't become american citizens that
fought like hell for us
mr yeah that's a terrific story um
and
uh one of the
areas where hoover unmistakably
came down on the right side of a very
controversial issue was on the
internment of japanese american citizens
hoover
advocated that that not be done he
recommended it not be done and his
reasons were very clear
he and his bureau had been on top of the
nazi and the japanese underground in
this country
and within hours after pearl harbor they
had rounded up
everyone that they considered to be
involved in espionage and potential
sabotage activities in the united states
and so
he told his superiors that there was no
reason
to round up the
nisei
to round up
these people and furthermore
that all that was happening was response
to
unjustified austerity on the west coast
and furthermore hoover was then asked
later on in the
war to make an investigation of the
law enforcement situation within the
internment camps and once again in the
course of making that investigation he
pointed out that the whole thing was
unjustifiable
mr powers we have we're almost out of
time but i wanted just to get you
quickly to uh i wanted to go through all
the presidents and i think there were
seven that j edgar hoover served during
their administrations but what about the
best and the worst relationship with the
president
the best relationship best working
relationship with was with franklin d
roosevelt
uh roosevelt gave hoover some very
difficult jobs to do
during the mid 30s when the isolationist
and anti-war sentiment was so strong in
this country
roosevelt knew a war was on its way he
of course was trying to rearm the
country but is also trying to stay on
top of the
nazi movement in this country and for
that matter of the communist movement in
this country and so in a very delicate
way hoover got the bureau back into the
business of domestic surveillance of
these foreign affiliated groups he did a
great job
during world war ii he also performed a
great service for franklin roosevelt in
staying on top of nazi saboteur
activities and so forth so that was
really the most productive relationship
in
hoover's career
the worst relationships well there were
two of them really one was under harry
truman when hoover all but pitted the
fbi against the truman administration on
the communist and government issue
he was very disloyal to uh harry truman
and then there was john f kennedy and
once again this was a president that
toover despised
uh and a president whose values he
really rejected on the other hand in a
couple instances he proved himself to be
a loyal soldier to john f kennedy let's
see if we can squeeze in at least one
more phone call here for richard
goodpower scottsburg indiana good
morning yes sir uh mr pires uh
i had a brother who uh was in world war
ii he was on iwo jima in guam he later
went tonight's ghoul became a lawyer
went with the fbi worked with him for a
number of years and finally when he
died he was working with the house
appropriations committee and recently my
nephew sent me a lot of information
there's a lot of correspondence in there
some of it uh pretty
detailed
and i just wondered if you were aware
that
they gave a an incentive award to some
of the
i guess the agents for work well done it
seems like a fitness today but uh
he got 164 dollars that was a 200 award
uh less taxes
and
i was wondering if he was aware that
they that they did that you know it i
was looking at some of the
correspondence and it showed that he
really uh did a great job on several
cases and he got these awards where uh
you know foreign intelligence and a lot
of other things were involved it seems
like not too much by today's standards
you know i just wonder if he was aware
of that
yeah i was and the
the method that hoover used to stay on
top of his agents involved constant
reporting but also constant awarding of
either demerits or merits and the
demerits would cost the agents money and
the merits would give them some money
so
it was a
a carrot and stick approach that was
applicable all through hoover's era
richard goodpowers is the author of this
book secrecy and power the life of j
edgar hoover and mr powers thank you
very much for being with us this morning
it was enjoyable appreciate it and for
our viewers and listeners just a few
quick program notes congressman james
traficant his hearing before the house
ethics committee day three